ahora gómez usted ha sido seleccionada
recientemente por la biblioteca de la
ciudad de toronto para una residencia de
artistas emprendedores puede por favor
explicarnos de qué se trata esto
bueno louis primero que todo espero que
estés teniendo un gran día igual que
para todas las personas que se conectan
y hacen parte del programa efectivamente
la librería de toronto que ha creado una
residencia donde permite que un un
artista o un artista emprendedora pueda
entrar en un proceso de conversación con
otros y otras artistas especialmente
artistas visuales para hablar sobre
procesos de emprendimiento en mi caso y
la propuesta que yo mandé a las la
ciudad de toros por tanto a la librería
de toronto es la visión de un
emprendimiento artístico con un
contenido social es me he movido siempre
desde esa desde ese espacio desde el
espacio donde donde un abusar sus
talentos y sus habilidades para también
contribuir al crecimiento y al
fortalecimiento de las comunidades y
entonces la propuesta se basa y bueno
otra cosa que quiero decir es que
la primera residencia que ocurre o sea
que la parte que es muy poderosa es el
hecho de que tenemos la oportunidad de
de formar este espacio de crear esa
plataforma de imaginar no la en este
momento pero también cómo va a ser el
futuro
y también reconociendo louis el hecho de
que como artistas también somos
emprendedores por sí porque tenemos
estas ideas las las pensamos y las
llevamos a una a una resolución aunque
ha sido cierto que a los artistas y a
las artistas se nos ha vendido la idea
de que tenemos que sacrificarnos de que
no podemos obtener dinero por nuestra
labor artística y el discurso del
artista hambriento ha ganado una gran
visibilidad al punto de que las familias
desaniman a sus a sus adolescentes a que
sigan carreras artísticas porque muy
pocas veces nos imaginamos al artista
como una persona de éxito
yo quiero pues hacer un paréntesis ahí
como una persona que hace este trabajo
de emprendimiento social quiero decir
que el éxito es una cosa individual y
cada quien tiene una idea de éxito
diferente pero cuando yo hablo aquí
cuando usó una palabra de éxito yo estoy
haciendo referencia al hecho de poder
cubrir las necesidades que ocurren al
vivir en un sistema capitalista como en
el que vivimos donde necesitamos un
recurso financiero para poder comer para
poder vestir para poder tener una
vivienda entonces habló del éxito como
la posibilidad a través del arte de tu
arte de lo que tú haces poder cubrir las
necesidades básicas que te permiten
primero tener un estilo de vida
saludable digno y que puedas cubrir los
gastos que implica tu práctica artística
y eso en sí pues ha sido bastante
bastante poderoso porque otra cosa que
vos o que yo que he querido involucrar
en esta residencia louis es el hecho de
crear una exacto una estructura de
colonizadora y es que y esto es un poco
como relacionado a lo que veníamos
hablando antes de entrar la entrevista y
es como reconocernos como nos
reconocemos a nosotros mismos y ellos y
aquellos que están a nuestro alrededor
que sus talentos sus habilidades sus
experiencias de vida son valiosas y que
no existe sólo una forma de ser artista
o de poder adquirir recursos sino muchas
y múltiples formas en las que una cabra
nosotros puede observar y respirar el
éxito a quizás aquellos emprendimientos
que esas actividades en los que
participas son concebidos en buena
manera como un espacio de participación
artístico pero sobre todo o incluyendo
en todo caso a los artistas que surgen
de la inmigración
y retomando esta idea ya que era una de
las preguntas de hecho que había
previsto hacerle retomando esta idea
suya de luchar contra la concepción del
artista pobre es posible para un
inmigrante específicamente
involucrado en el desarrollo de la del
arte vivir aquí en canadá de su
actividad
louis pues yo digo que es posible porque
yo soy un ejemplo de esas posibilidades
verdad y cómo y cómo y como yo existen
múltiples artistas que han entrado en un
proceso y en los proyectos y en unas
iniciativas en las que han permitido o
que les han permitido explorar las
diferentes formas en las que pueden
generar unos ingresos para que puedan
uno continuar con sus prácticas
artísticas dos que puedan considerar su
práctica artística como una carrera y
tres que puedan proyectarse no sólo
desde reconocer desde reconocernos como
artistas exitosos o con influencia o un
impacto en este espacio sino también de
reconocer que que podemos tener impactos
en otros lugares o sea reconocer nuestra
experiencia internacional que ya la
tenemos por el hecho de venir de otro
país ya tenemos la experiencia
internacional la conare es reconocer esa
experiencia internacional como como un
valor agregado nuestro y no como algo
que va en detrimento
y aquí es donde yo digo que necesitamos
cómo cambiar el 'chip' y vernos a
nosotros mismos como estos artistas
inmigrantes refugiados o nuevos
inmigrantes como personas que vienen con
unos valores agregados ya venimos con
una experiencia con una práctica no
somos artistas emergentes sencillamente
artistas que vienen desde otro país con
otra experiencia y aquí necesitamos
ganar esta experiencia canadiense
entonces quiero pues redondear un poco
esa idea y responder más claramente esta
pregunta es si si es posible es muy
importante
practicar nuestra nuestra mente
emprendedora
y quiero clarificar que en inglés yo no
digo emprendedor sí sino que digo arte
pero qué significa en entrelazar la
palabra artista y emprendedor al mismo
tiempo no sabría cómo jugar con esas
palabras en español pero es que es lo
que quiero reconocer es que el artista
no es cualquier tipo de emprendedor o
sea nosotros no nos funciona el asunto y
no es que lo vamos a dejar mañana y
tratantes hará otra cosa nueva
no el artista va a ser artista todos los
días de su vida el creativo hacer
creativo todos los días de su vida el
asunto es cómo utilizar esas habilidades
que ya tenemos para poder reconocer que
a través de esas actividades podemos
generar los recursos que nos permiten
una calidad de vida y cubrir nuestras
necesidades cuando yo digo que soy un
ejemplo de ello
yo quiero traer la atención a los
emprendimientos sociales con que hemos
empezado con mi compañero y uno de ellos
es news arts que vamos a hablar de un
poco más tarde que es un proyecto de
arte comunitario que empezó inicialmente
con un colectivo entre mi compañero y yo
y hacíamos proyectos de comunidad
los proyectos de la comunidad son
proyectos bastante poderosos pero
también nos aseguramos que si bien es
cierto la comunidad no nos paga a
nosotros por hacer el proyecto nosotros
tocábamos las puertas para acceder a los
recursos que permitieran que nos pagaran
a nosotros por hacer el trabajo y que
nos permitirán también pagar los
materiales para hacer los trabajos de
manera tal que nuestras comunidades no
tengan que pagar un centavo
los proyectos han ido incrementando de
manera tal que después de ocho años nos
convertimos en una ford profit donde
donde nosotros dos somos directores y
trabajamos empleados de la organización
lo cual está perfectamente bien y es una
genera unos ingresos pero lo que quiero
y la razón por la cual pongo mi
información de frente es porque quiero
decir que a través de ese proceso
también han ocurrido otras cosas
maravillosas o sea yo soy consultora
artística porque mi experiencia me ha
permitido crear ese espacio soy
profesora universitaria en el tema de
las artes porque ese espacio me ha
permitido crear esas habilidades y
potencializar esas habilidades lo que
quiero decir con esto es que mi
formación artística como escritora de
informaciones artísticas como como como
comodín gays artes y perdón que estoy
usando esa palabra en inglés bueno está
comprometido en arte estás como una
artista que trabaja directamente en
comunidad un artista comunitario esa
sería la palabra esas prácticas son la
base de mis emprendimientos
pero que cuando yo me iba al trabajo que
tengo que hacer yo lo potencializar de
qué manera yo puedo seguir haciendo mi
trabajo y al mismo tiempo puedo
garantizar que los recibos que llegan al
final de mes se cubren entonces en esta
residencia artística en la en la con la
librería de toronto pues no solo estoy
compartiendo mi experiencia pero estoy
invitando a ocho artistas de diferentes
orígenes de diferentes estilos de vida
entre ellos inmigrantes refugiados y
artistas indígenas de aquí del
territorio que conocemos como canadá
para que nos cuenten cuáles son sus
experiencias y cuáles han sido la forma
en la que esos emprendimientos han
llegado a un momento en los que ellos
sienten que
y ha llegado como esa cima que les
permite decir si soy este artista que no
es el artista hambriento que no está
celebrando el romantic zando la pobreza
sino que decimos podemos tener unos unos
estilos de vida que nos permite vivir
dignamente estamos estamos diciendo que
aquí con el arte te vas a volver bien
pero estamos diciendo que que no que
tenemos que salirnos de la idea del
artista hambriento sobre todo porque
necesitamos seguir animando a nuestros
niños ya nuestros jóvenes a que
gestionen ideas y prácticas creativas
porque la creatividad permite que cada
uno de nosotros tenga la habilidad de de
sobrepasar las adversidades pero también
tiene la posibilidad de hacer gente más
feliz cuando tú haces lo que tú amas y
lo que te apasiona tú tienes este
sentimiento de plenitud y del disfrute
que nada más lo va a cubrir en tu vida
entonces por qué no crear espacios donde
reconocemos que el arte no sólo genera
eso para las comunidades pero también es
un gran
una gran forma de llegar y cumplir tu
propósito en la vida si les permitimos a
nuestros jóvenes ser eso lo que ellos
sueñan ser paula y precisamente para que
esos artistas que nos puedan estar
escuchando y se interesen en esta idea
de muse arts como se pueden poner en
contacto cómo pueden participar cómo se
pueden sumar ningún caso a esa propuesta
bueno si hablando específicamente de los
proyectos de news arts que es una que es
una organización de arte comunitario
localiza aquí en la ciudad de toronto
nosotros bueno primero que todo pues
bienvenidos a que nos visiten en nuestra
página web que es la www.uva.es news
marks punto sea y obviamente pues
estamos en las redes sociales bajo su
nombre somos bastante ágiles para
responderles las preguntas y conectando
con la gente en cualesquiera de esos
medios sociales
pero también quiero compartirles que
nosotros tenemos un proyecto de
intercambio cultural con américa y el
caribe y hacemos una residencia
artística en colombia y tenemos
proyectos de emprendimiento con ecuador
y con y con méxico también es decir que
creamos espacios donde artistas de
méxico ecuador y colombia
entramos en procesos de intercambio de
culturas de conocimientos de saberes y
creemos en la cooperación internacional
no desde la perspectiva de que vamos a
ir a resolver los problemas a alguien
sino desde el reconocimiento de que un
espacio de iguales tenemos la capacidad
de aprender los unos de los otros y ese
trabajo de nuevo todo es posible todos
los artistas como tú mencionadas al
principio y louis en nuestro trabajo
está enfocado en darle visibilidad al
arte producido por artistas inmigrantes
nuevos inmigrantes y refugiados y si hay
dentro de las personas que están
escuchándonos o viendo no sólo leyendo
esta nota
están muy bienvenidos a que se contacten
con nosotros a través de nuestra página
web y de seguro que vamos a empezar una
conversación para saber cómo podemos ser
de utilidad pero sobre todo cómo podemos
construir e imaginar espacios en el
futuro en juntos y juntas ahora dentro
de esta inmensa actividad que desarrolla
figura además un festival del cual
también ustedes es impulsora háblenos de
esta idea también por favor pues ya
quiero contarte que es el festival
realmente empezó como todos los
emprendimientos y estoy segura que
cuando estoy hablando de esto esto
resuena con muchas personas y yo soy de
las que cree que cuando la que cuando la
puerta está cerrada pues uno lo que
tiene que hacer es ir a construir otra
entonces este festival empezó hace cinco
años porque sentíamos que no había un
espacio
que valoraba al arte y ahí el artista de
inmigrantes refugiados 9 inmigrantes por
su por el talento que traemos osea yo no
solo necesito que me muestren como si
fuera esta este objeto novedoso y sofía
y exótico o para llenar las listas como
el check list de las organizaciones
grandes diciendo así tenemos refugiados
así tenemos latinos así tenemos
personas de color se saben del que
listas lo estoy hablando de gracias se
siente más como si fuera un toque que si
fuera alguien valorado entonces
pues no me gustaba ese sentimiento de no
podemos crear algo porque es que yo no
solo soy recibido ahora de cosas o sea
como emigrante yo no sólo vengo aquí a
que el aquel que a sentirme agradecida
porque me están dando no no no yo
también doy también contribuye también
también creó comunidad también construyó
paz entonces pues construimos un
festival y el festival empieza por un
día y luego ya este momento es un mes de
acciones comunitarias donde llevamos
arte a diferentes espacios nosotros le
apostamos a trabajar con el vecindario y
le apostamos a trabajar en los parques
mostrar el arte donde sea posible de una
instalación hasta una danza folklórica y
obviamente también pues tenemos bastante
presencia en el ámbito virtual también y
pues esto ha generado y esto es bastante
importante del hecho de que nuestro
trabajo no sólo se centra en la
migración o en los procesos migratorios
de nuestras comunidades latinoamericanas
donde estamos supremamente orgullosos de
ser
sino que también trabajamos con muchos
artistas de siria de irán de la india de
varios países en áfrica o sea nuestro
nuestro grupo de artistas puede ser un
grupo el año pasado teníamos
listos para presentar 100 artistas
ocurrió la ocurrió la pandemia decidimos
no cancelar y movimos migramos el
festival a una a una plataforma virtual
donde pudimos presentar 70 a los
artistas bien sea haciendo
presentaciones en un vídeo o bien sea
apartada haciendo parte de un panel o
una discusión la idea es que queremos
darle la visibilidad y creemos que esta
plataforma que yo realmente llamo
comunidad yo esta comunidad de artistas
de happening los llamo comunidad porque
porque yo pienso también que a nosotros
nos han enseñado mucho a pensar
individualmente ya decir ahí no tengo
que sólo mirar como como cómo llegó yo
porque eso es el sistema competitivo
cierto la propuesta con happen en es una
propuesta que dice no vamos a celebrar
nos los unos a los otros y si tú te
ganas el gran yo también lo voy a
celebrar si es abeja te la ganas tú la
celebro contigo porque un logro tuyo
como inmigrante es un logro mío también
porque lo que estamos haciendo es
tratando de desmitificar la idea de que
el inmigrante y el refugiado viene a
quitar y porque no reconocemos que el
inmigrante y el refugiado viene al dar a
contribuir que también traemos todos los
valores agregados de los que hablaba al
principio y por eso siempre digo pues
aquí estoy yo de ejemplo si yo puedo
hacerlo cada una de las personas que nos
escuchan nos ven con un link lo pueden
hacer también vamos a nombrarlo porque
lo dijimos el nombre completo en ningún
momento es el happening multi culto el
festival que se lleva a cabo este año
cuando ya lo aclaró que está más volcado
en la plataforma
digital por razones obvias por la
pandemia que nos afecta a todos pero más
allá de eso cuando en qué momento se
lleva a cabo este año es imperfecto si
sabemos que connections festival
es una acción de un mes completo en el
mes de mayo y tiene unas acciones de
activación comunitaria quiere decir que
nos vamos a la comunidad a hacer
trabajos tiene también una plataforma
virtual donde donde hacemos paneles como
decía se llama hacemos artist spotlight
y también tiene una plataforma de solo
presentación de arte en diferentes
géneros de arte y formas artísticas como
la danza la poesía la música que está
solo
orientado a darle el spotlight o la
visibilidad o la luz central a los
artistas nuevas migrantes y refugiados
igual que los artistas inmigrantes
también tenemos una ceremonia de premios
del reconocimiento que se llama
las comunidades en power and communities
donde diez artistas de muchos de muchos
orígenes se ganan este premio y esa la
forma en la que nosotros abrimos el
festival que abre en los primeros días
de mayo y va de mayo de mayo creo que de
mayo 3 hasta mayo 28 que es un domingo
este año el plan era hacer una cosa
grande afuera en el parque no podemos
hacerlo así de grande pero igual vamos a
tener la presencia afuera vamos a hacer
instalaciones grandes que la gente sepa
que esto fue hecho por talento
inmigrante por talento refugiado porque
nosotros nos han vendido ese estigma de
que el refugiado de pronto es peligroso
de que el refugiado es alguien que ha
venir a vivir del gobierno pues yo
quiero anunciar que el spektrum de ser
refugiado tiene muchas variantes y que
las necesidades de cada uno de nosotros
yo soy refugiada
son diferentes y que cuando estamos
listos cuando ya hemos superado ese
trauma que hemos vivido porque a mí me
pasó pues estaremos listos para hacer
miembros activos de nuestras comunidades
como es en mi caso y por los últimos 10
años haciendo un trabajo directo en arte
comunitario como estoy mencionando o
haciendo un trabajo con mujeres
sobrevivientes de violencia como lo he
hecho desde que llegué a este país
entonces esto cómo puedes escucharme
louis está muy orientado a desmitificar
esta idea que se vende a veces por la
ola por los medios de comunicación donde
se presenta al refugiado única y
exclusivamente como esa pobre persona
que está que que puede ser quitarle
tanto al sistema porque es muy
necesitada o como es exitoso que es que
hace fábricas y que claro a mucha gente
no en el espectro en ese rango hay
tantas personas y somos tantos seres
humanos de tantas formas de vida de
tantas culturas que lo único que
queremos es poder encontrar un lugar que
que nos pueda [ __ ] y que nos pueda
recibir y que pueda convertirse en
nuestros hogares y que en ese proceso
también damos y contribuimos
personas de diferentes habilidades y
capacidades que permiten a estas
sociedades ser tan tan tan poderosas y
tan importantes como lo son porque el
trabajo de cada uno de los otros el tuyo
louis el mío hace parte de lo que
construye estas comunidades por último
paula porque nos quedan solamente
algunos segundos hay preguntas trilladas
que recuperan valor cuando el
entrevistado tiene algo para decir cómo
es este el caso y entonces aunque la
respuesta creo que ella es obvia por
todo lo que hemos estado hablando el
arte puede cambiar realidades
louis yo soy una convencida de que el
arte cambia realidades de que el arte
transforma el mundo pero que el arte
también puede ser una estrategia de vida
que nos permite a cada uno y a cada uno
de nosotros lograr nuestros sueños y que
nos permite vivir en mundos más justos
paula gómez muchas gracias por esta
entrevista con radio canadá
internacional
muchas veces a ti louis por la
invitación